[Music]
on this thursday night explosions rock
ukraine's capital
new missile strikes on central keeve as
the u.n secretary general is in the city
for talks with ukraine's president the
u.s pledges tens of billions of dollars
more to ukraine and families go on
heartbreaking searches for loved ones
ban banished it's about time canada's
landmark decision who is no longer
forbidden from donating blood turning
off the taps the feud between some
alberta farmers and a first nation and
what resolved it plus astronomical gold
we need that footprint the hopes and
hurdles in creating canada's first
commercial space facility
[Music]
the terrifying sounds of war have once
again reached ukraine's capital
president vladimir zelinsky says five
rockets targeted keeve tonight the
city's mayor says two of them hit
sending plumes of black smoke billowing
over a residential district emergency
responders say one person has been
killed and several others injured
good evening and thanks for joining us
those missiles hit soon after the
secretary general of the u.n met
president zielinski in kiev antonio
guterres is safe but ukraine's defense
minister calls the missile strikes an
attack on the security of the secretary
general and on the world just two days
ago guterres was at the kremlin trying
to negotiate with russia's president to
end the violence today the u.n chief
toured towns near kiev where russian
troops are accused of committing war
crimes and he voiced his support for a
thorough investigation and
accountability by the international
criminal court
a warning our coverage tonight includes
some disturbing images we begin in kiev
where those missiles hit not long ago
crystal commansing is there crystal
donna we could hear those explosions off
in the distance and no sooner were we
cleared from our shelter that a second
set of explosions could be heard loud
bangs very close to us in fact we could
not only smell fire but we could see one
burning as well the fact that this
happened during the u.n secretary
general's visit leaves little to doubt
and like the u.n secretary general who
visited bucha we were also there that
city has really endured a lot of the
horrors of this war
it is a small white tent but the
structure gives shelter to those seeking
answers every day dozens of survivors
come here searching for their dead loved
ones
this woman found her 15 year old
grandson's body her cries set against
the steady hum of the refrigerator truck
holding his remains
and so many others
agonizing searches have been ongoing
since the moment russian forces were
driven out of bucha the city's 50 000
residents were bombed and terrorized for
days
bucha was considered the most dangerous
place near keith
my work day is like this they are
calling calling calling and it's like
hundreds of people i have to talk every
day work at the morgue is never ending
tanks have been removed streets cleared
but for the residents of bucha who
survived they are now in another phase
of this war
grief we opened here
information center as the butcher city
council and we are helping relatives to
find their
killed or died
moms fathers daughters sons and so on
workers and volunteers can appear
expressionless perhaps numb to the
relentless horrors of the war that
they've endured perhaps they're simply
too busy to pause and reflect
the silence of this busy site is broken
only by the occasional mourner or the
calls from crows nesting in the trees
above
the hundreds of bodies brought here are
from where they died on the streets or
exhumed from mass graves women and
children are among them if we look at
the figure 412
that means every third in cave region so
every third in kiev region were killed
was killed here in bucha well the images
of bodies piled up is graphic and
unsettling the work happening here is
actually critical the bodies will hold
evidence potentially answering key
questions about what happened here that
can be used by international
investigators to build a war crimes case
against russia
two teams spend every morning here
performing post-mortems and then
meticulously documenting their findings
in the afternoon
i wake up every morning at 3 o'clock and
victor and yuri already in front of my
eyes nadia valentina and sirhi found
their two relatives after a month-long
search they tell us it appears nadia's
ex-husband and his brother were tortured
their loss is devastating especially for
certi i wouldn't talk about it cried and
shouted so loudly begging them to live a
life at least one of them for him
it is impossible to escape the horrors
of this war and some of those bearing
witness to it are so young
they'll carry the memories for a
lifetime
there are still so many unidentified
bodies french forensic teams working on
the ground in bucha are starting to use
dna technology they're taking swabs from
the remains so that it'll be easier to
connect remains with relatives when they
come searching but that technology won't
be in place to help out until next week
donna all right crystal commencing in
kiev ukraine tonight thanks
russia claims the u.s and poland are
plotting to invade western ukraine and
occupy it in a statement the chief of
russia's foreign intelligence service
cited unpublished intelligence claiming
washington and warsaw are working to
establish tight military and political
control over what he calls poland's
historical possessions in ukraine polish
officials say it is not true that it's
more russian disinformation intended to
drive a wedge between poland and ukraine
today the american president reiterated
his message that russia is the aggressor
and joe biden said as long as atrocities
continue the u.s will continue to supply
weapons to ukraine
despite the disturbing rhetoric coming
out of the kremlin the facts are plain
for everybody to see
we're not attacking russia we're helping
ukraine defend itself against russian
aggression
biden has asked congress for another 33
billion dollars in aid and weapons to
ukraine to signal the u.s is preparing
to help key for the long haul and
canada's defense minister says our
troops are training their ukrainian
counterparts on how to use the howitzers
canada has sent anita anand was in
washington today for meetings at the
pentagon abigail beeman has those
developments
anita anand arrives at the pentagon for
her first official visit as canada's
defense minister
you know we don't have a better friend
than canada the u.s defense secretary
commended canada for this week's
announcement our country is sending
eight armored vehicles to ukraine and on
the m triple seven howitzers canada sent
last week i can confirm
that canadian soldiers are now training
their ukrainian counterparts in the use
of these weapons it's no surprise that
we had such a highly productive meeting
today the pair met for just under an
hour no specific commitments came of it
but the conversation extended beyond
ukraine to include norad the arctic and
climate resilience it's a very complex
chess game going on horse training going
on behind closed doors one analyst
believes talks would have included what
the u.s may do to backfill canada's
weapons supply what we can promise the
ukrainians in part depends on the
american willingness to help us restock
so
i think the conversation is very much
about well we'll do this if you do that
earlier this week defense secretary
lloyd austin made headlines saying the
goal is to weaken russia we want to see
russia
weakened to the degree that it can't do
the kinds of things that
it has done in invading ukraine asked
about that today canada's prime minister
stayed far away from such strong
language we are united
in wanting to see russia not just pay
for this terrible decision
but be held accountable for it in terms
of canadians training ukrainians on the
howitzers anita anand did not offer any
specifics a canadian government source
would only say that training is not
happening on ukrainian soil donna
abigail beeman at the pentagon thanks
canada's foreign affairs minister
melanie jolie says ottawa is moving
forward with new legislation that would
enable canada to not only freeze the
assets of russians who have been
sanctioned but seize the assets and
liquidate them giving the money to
ukrainian war victims and to help
rebuild ukraine it's working with g7
allies to craft legislation and today
washington signaled it plans to follow
suit jolie was at the senate foreign
affairs committee in ottawa today she
says canada and its allies must be ready
for all scenarios including russia
deploying nuclear weapons
clearly uh their invasion is a failure
and will continue to be a failure and we
won't
stop
our efforts until
ukraine wins
jolie also says canada intends to reopen
its embassy in kiev soon
the federal government is giving nearly
six million dollars more to canada's
special envoy on preserving holocaust
remembrance and fighting anti-semitism
preserving the truth of the survivors
also includes ensuring that we have the
places that will hold these stories over
the years to come
the announcement was made during a
ceremony for holocaust remembrance day
the federal government will roll out the
new funding over the next five years
now to the federal government's policies
on the environment canada's
environmental watchdog says the
government is being impractical about
reducing emissions and that it's likely
impossible for the government to reach
its emission targets over the next eight
years eric sorenson on the report and
the reaction
the city of winnipeg is testing clean
hydrogen fuels turning big city buses
into zero emissions vehicles ottawa
believes hydrogen will help meet its
2030 carbon emissions targets but
canada's environment commissioner says
in his report the government is not
being realistic for example natural
resources canada estimates clean
hydrogen could reduce carbon emissions
up to 45 megatons by 2030 while
environment and climate change canada
estimates reductions of just 15 megatons
while the environment commissioner
himself says both are making unrealistic
assumptions for modeling the potential
of hydrogen the assumptions in the
federal hydrogen strategy are overly
optimistic and compromise the
credibility of the expected
emission reductions when it comes to
paying taxes for carbon emissions the
commissioner's report found big
industrial polluters disproportionately
pay less than smaller businesses and
indigenous groups while ottawa's program
allows provinces to have different
pricing schemes it's a weak program and
it gives the sense to some that
industry isn't paying its fair share
compared to everyday canadians
reaching targets will only take longer
say experts if some industries get
unfair exemptions not
addressing the larger polluters today
is going to delay
the fastest transition later for workers
in fossil fuel industries the commission
says ottawa still hasn't introduced
promised legislation to help them
transition to new jobs they talk about a
just transition from oil and gas but
provide no support to canadian energy
workers who are losing their jobs the
minister of environment pointed to
successes while acknowledging the
government must do more the commissioner
said that the federal government would
reach its 25 emission reduction target
this year not in 2025 our plan is
working i'll agree that there's way more
we need to do indeed the environment
commissioner says canada lags behind
other g7 countries in reducing
greenhouse gases we cannot afford a
fourth decade of failure on climate
action and the climate change clock he
says never stops ticking eric sorensen
global news toronto
a major modification to blood donation
rules coming up the new criteria for
giving the gift of life
[Music]
there is a big policy change about blood
donations in canada gay men will no
longer be automatically banned from
donating something that's long been
considered discriminatory and homophobic
the new policy will screen all donors
about their sexual behavior regardless
of gender or sexual orientation as jamie
morocco reports advocates say it's about
time
patients across canada need donors more
than ever and by the end of september
more canadians will be eligible to offer
an arm including 34 year old anthony
falls who is blood type o a universal
donor it's about time
it still shocks me in 2022 that as a gay
male i actually can donate blood in
canada since 1992 any man who had sex
with another man was barred from giving
the gift of life over concerns the gay
community was at higher risk to transmit
hiv
over the last decade health canada
okayed canadian blood services to relax
the donor deferral policy in 2019 it was
reduced to three months
the three-month rule didn't make sense
because the chances of them bringing hiv
into the blood system was so incredibly
low
now all donors will be equally screened
for sexual behavior regardless of their
gender or sexual orientation that to us
is a an inclusive process a fair process
and one that is rooted in science and
evidence advocates have been demanding
federal intervention for years
criticized for moving too slowly prime
minister justin trudeau has made
recurrent pledges to lift the ban we're
ending the blanket ban
on msm donations
but it took too long
this should have been done
10 years ago 15 years ago years of lost
contributions registered nurse tyler
watt has been wanting to make up for we
are constantly facing shortages of blood
you know i've actually witnessed it in
my own practice glad his sexuality will
no longer determine whether he can be
part of the solution jamie morocco
global news toronto
ahead water rights why an alberta first
nation turned off the taps to farmers
there is a new development tonight in
the federal government's long-standing
promise to end boil water advisories on
first nations the minister of indigenous
services says the claims period is now
open for compensation applications the
money comes from a class action lawsuit
settlement initiated in 2019 nearly 8
billion dollars is being made available
for those deprived of clean drinking
water and for things like the
modernization of canada's first nations
drinking water legislation
it's unfortunate that we have lost so
many over the years
including my late son
who never got a chance
to drink
from the top
prime minister trudeau promised to end
all long-term drinking water advisories
by 2021 132 advisories have been lifted
33 remain in effect
water is flowing once again to farmers
in southern alberta after a two-week
long protest caused fields to go dry
it's a dispute over water rights the
lethbridge irrigation district draws
water from a river but relies on a
diversion weir on a nearby first nation
and at the start of this month
indigenous leaders turned off the tap
heather urex west explains why
all the irrigation is run by separate
water for cattle farmer troy bischler
water is life the producers in this area
we're talking a quarter million head of
cattle that need water every day so when
the canals around here began to go dry
farmers like bischler grew anxious but
it's not just livestock being impacted
all these fields rely on irrigation and
without water the hay and cereal crops
will suffer
this part of southern alberta doesn't
see a lot of rain agriculture depends on
water diverted from the old man river a
river that runs through the pakani
nation reserve
every spring the canal gates open from a
weir on pakani land but on april 12th
the nation closed it tight at times
where we get very protective of our
river it's sacred to us councilor real
hull says the act of protest wasn't
taken lightly he says 20 years after a
water rights agreement was first signed
between the nation and the federal and
provincial governments a lot has changed
for one the province wants to build a
new upgraded weir the province wants to
come in and build a new one
and beginning nation wants to be a part
of that
because you know it's a it's a major
project that's happening on our lands
houl says after five years of writing to
the province with environmental and
economic concerns turning off the taps
was finally an act of desperation but it
worked we're finally moving in a good
direction
but you know to be honest heather
you know it took the ninth hour for them
to come and talk to the beginning nation
two weeks later the province and the
pakani reached an agreement to start
working together and the gate was opened
up again the pakani need to have have a
seat at the table and be part of the
conversation to make sure that any work
that we do
on the way or any of the infrastructure
system is protecting the environment
long term so this is a really good
example of the long term and even
contemporary effects of failing to
resolve these historical disputes and
like i say there are literally hundreds
of these across the country
but for the hundreds of disputes between
first nations groups and governments
across canada infrastructure disrupting
protests like the ones that blocked rail
lines in early 2020 are exceedingly rare
in most cases indigenous groups take
these battles to court where they often
win then the question comes why are we
not resolving them more quickly in the
end no lengthy court battle was
necessary for the pakani nation just an
act of desperation and a couple of dry
anxious weeks heather urex west global
news
calgary
next high hopes to connect a small town
in nova scotia with space
there are hopes for atlantic canada to
make some space history a canadian
company has been working hard to get
this country's first commercial
spaceport built in nova scotia it's all
still coming together and there have
been a few setbacks including russia's
invasion of ukraine ross lord on the
plans and the obstacles
with more rockets than ever blasting off
into space for expanding satellite
technology or for wealthy celebrities to
get their kicks
why not make canada a rocket launching
center canada doesn't have a footprint
uh
directly right now into the
in into space for launching the
satellites and we're putting hundreds of
satellites in space
uh you know so we need that we need that
footprint that footprint a spaceport
could be near cancel nova scotia an
historic fishing community that's
struggled since the cod collapse of the
90s the developer maritime launch
services says it's acquired the land
needed for the launch pad and control
center and is working on final
environmental approvals we've done
you know a significant uh portion of the
compliance pieces that came with the ea
approval
you know wetland mitigation plan
wildlife management plan the company
says it chose the kanso area because its
remote location makes it a safe place
for launching satellite technology into
space
its current plan is a test launcher
sorts next year blasting a rocket past
the 100 kilometer threshold that's
considered the beginning of space
money-making flights would follow but
the spaceport is already running behind
schedule and there's a new concern the
war in ukraine where maritime launch's
supplier of medium-range rockets is
based the company says the war has not
disrupted operations yet working in its
favor the federal government has
expressed support and maritime launch is
now asking for government funding after
saying it would not pursue tax dollars
hoping the right boosters will seal the
deal
ross lord global news
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen tonight's
york canada is this view of banff
alberta from the top of sulphur mountain
a stunning spot we'd love to see your
canada please email it to us and thanks
for watching chris gales will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow and i will see you
on saturday for the new reality bye bye
[Applause]
[Music]